I am NOT a big fan of Republicans in
general you know that Pat people in the
audience know that I did not vote for
Massachusetts Republican governor
Charlie Baker but when he has been right
I've not been afraid to tell you that he
did the right thing and governor Charlie
Baker you can call him a Massachusetts
Republican you can call him you know for
the coffee fiends like Pat maybe
something like a decaf Republican
Republican Lite Republican Lite is a
more a vegan Republican I don't know
maybe that's inappropriate he is putting
his foot down and he is refusing to send
any Massachusetts National Guard troops
to the border because of what he sees as
the immoral and inhuman escalation by
the Trump administration of separating
and detaining the children of
undocumented immigrants in these
concentration camp like centers
including the upcoming Fort Bliss Texas
location I've told you about where
temperatures regularly exceed 100
degrees Fahrenheit so caveats about the
decision by Charlie Baker number one
this is not some incredibly difficult
heroic politically risky move by Charlie
Baker he's a Republican in Massachusetts
and the policy that we are seeing
escalated by the Trump administration
with these kids is widely deplored
number two Baker should have refused to
deploy National Guard troops to the
border from the get-go right and even
though now he is getting some accolades
for saying I'm not gonna do the Trump
thing I'm not going to send more troops
down there he already agreed to do it
before right and for that we should
still be critical of him so I have my
two sides pat on the one hand this has
been a hyper partisan issue right
Democrats and Republicans just have not
seen eye-to-eye about putting kids in
cages every Democratic senator has
signed on to legislation to stop this
insanity Republicans basically have not
this morning Ted Cruz did say that he
has an idea of how he would be able to
end this right away and it's a good
thing that as a Republican Charlie Baker
is at least doing something from the
state level but Charlie Baker did the
wrong thing when he originally agreed to
send National Guard troops down to the
us-mexico border for Donald Trump and so
while we want to acknowledge that he's
doing the correct
he actually all along should have said
no I'm not gonna send National Guard
troops down there to begin with yeah I
agree I don't doubt that Charlie Baker
is a good person at heart and I'm sure
this policy by Trump perks him in some
way but he's also making a political
calculation he's up for re-election in
2018 and he's in a blue state like
Massachusetts he is indeed and I was
thinking this morning how does the party
the Republican Party that is against
abortion on the basis that it's the
murder of a child who just hasn't been
born yet how is it that they seem to not
have a problem with actual life altering
child abuse of kids who have already
been born and it gets back to many
protections when they're in the womb
not so many protections once they're out
of the womb and actually in the real
world and then I remembered wait a
second they they almost voted in a
serial child sex assault er into the
United States Senate and I remembered oh
yeah it doesn't matter what they
actually do it matters whether they're
Republicans and this is sort of a good
opportunity to preempt some of the
criticism I'm going to receive people
will write to me and they'll say hey
David as I like to say it's sad but
these people are here illegally and
while the children aren't guilty of
anything we've got to be tough so that
the parents will stop bringing them
because it's an immigration wave that is
unstoppable and overwhelming and this
reminds me of when people want to talk
about Jewish related issues for example
and they say Jews are 10 or 15% of the
world population and it's actually point
19 percent if you don't know the basic
facts you're gonna have a hard time
having substantive discussions about
policy and here's the fact that's
missing listen carefully especially if
you're on the right undocumented
immigration has been on the decline for
a long time okay
the Pew Research Center study from 2000
occu mented immigration peaked in 2007
and it has been declining overall with
some small optics from any particular
year to the next undocumented immigrants
are going back to for example Mexico
faster than they're coming in
undocumented immigrants have lower crime
rates than
the general population because they know
they're undocumented and they don't want
to attract attention from law
enforcement is the issue of violent
criminal undocumented immigrants a real
problem yeah it exists and that should
be the narrow focus but this is not the
way to deal with that and it is stunning
how rarely the facts are actually
mentioned about undocumented immigration
and without those facts it's very easy
to fall into the Trump narrative of
fear-mongering around ms-13 members and
whatever else Trump says and that
becomes the narrative when the truth is
people are leaving more quickly than
they are coming in and not because of
deportations and what this gets to at
the very end right that when you
bottom-line this why do people come here
do people come here to be petty thieves
no do people come here to commit murder
outside of drug cartels stuff no not at
any higher rate than the murders we
birth on our own soil people mostly come
here with or without their kids for a
better life and to work a job not
exactly lazy criminals right and the
most productive and ethical and
economically beneficial way to curb
undocumented immigration is to help the
economies of the countries people come
from and stop negatively interfering in
those countries as the US has done so
many times before it's really
straightforward when the economy
improves in Nicaragua fewer Nicaraguans
are going to want to leave and come to
the United States illegally and in fact
part of the reason that there is a net
outflow to Mexico is because over the
last ten years the Mexican economy has
improved it's no panacea it's no amazing
circumstance in terms of median income
but as the Mexican economy has improved
you've seen a net outflow of Mexicans
back to Mexico and then lastly you got
to end the war on drugs that's the other
piece of this so the idea that were even
operating with the facts to figure out
what the right policy is is absolutely
and completely laughable